you have two daughters correct yeah
beautiful daughters would you want them
to be happy no I want them to be
productive and they will be happy to the
degree they're productive if they're
Free Loaders in society they will not be
happy no matter how much money no matter
what their car looks like their room
looks like their clothes look like if
they're not productive members
contributing to a society it is
impossible to be happy I don't know
anybody that is happy without being
productive what would you say to someone
now who's unhappy with their life and
they want to change things around I
would tell them to quit seeking
happiness and start seeking productivity
and contribution and helping other
people